welcome everyone to the uh meeting of
the cabinet of north east alberta
district council with us in the chamber
today we have uh councillor alan powell
uh councillor carolyn renick uh myself
council alex dale uh councillor jeremy
kenyon councillor charlotte cupid and
then we have jane dethick our finance
officer
kev shilato our legal officer
matt broughton
a transformation officer
and then on screen we have councilor
paul parkin
karen hanson one of our directors
jill calling in one of our directors
and then carl apps as well and alan
marr for from governance so welcome
everyone thank you very much for
uh joining us at the meeting again
another hybrid meeting for us all to
contend with but hopefully we're getting
used to them now um the first item's
apologies for absence we have had uh
some apologies from council foster who
is running late i'm not sure whether
that's
the zoom meeting or to the actual
meeting but uh but we'll soon see i'm
sure um i don't think there's been any
other apologies unless you have any
other to report on a non-received chair
okay lovely thank you uh declarations of
interest if there are any
no seed
okay thank you and then minutes the last
meeting we all had a chance to have a
look and are we happy to
uh
move in second okay
thank you all those in favor
okay they're approved
and then we come to the medium term
financial plan so i'll hand over to
council parking to present that thank
you thank you very much
so this is the mtfp financial outcome
for
20 the year 2020 to 2021
and the general purpose of this is to
inform the cabinet of the out-turn
position for that year
and to ask to approve the rollover of a
small number of revenue budgets uh and
the rollover of
uh some capital in the capital programme
um
the the accounts were published on the
17th of june ahead of the statutory
deadline so we met that deadline
and of course
the
draft accounts have been completed ahead
of this and and the
council's auditor mazars are sticking as
far as possible to their original work
schedule which means that
we should be i believe one of the first
councils
in the country if everything signed off
in time to get this to get this done so
uh but until mazzar sign off their
account the accounts there is a chance
that they may change a little uh but the
financial the the final audited accounts
will be reported to and approved by the
audit committee
uh on the 22nd of september
and so the report today considers the
outcome position for the general fund
hra capital program and treasury
management activity
uh and the key parts of this are to note
that
it's kind of the covet story if you like
um because what we've got here in table
one on page four
uh this summarizes the general fund
position and the important thing to note
here is the net cost of service under
spend which is around 627 k which kind
of reflects um you know those uh those
covered activities that we were unable
to do uh and therefore the costs of
costs have reduced there's a number of
other costs that have come down as a
result of that but this of course is is
a one one year
cost reduction in in future years we've
still got savings to make
uh table two on page five provides um
a breakdown of the variances identified
in table one
uh and the main variance is a pay
because
you know you struggle to recruit in a
pandemic uh and uh and there have been
a fair number of vacancies at that point
in time and of course an ndr
so the nndr variance relates to the
section 31 grants that we've received uh
in order to offset the reliefs that
we've been giving to businesses during
lockdown
these grants are received in the general
fund during 20 the year 2020 21 i won't
be moved to the collection fund uh until
2021 22 and and uh
i guess it's just one of those things
where we've got some money that we that
we need to move into the collection fund
in the next in the next year so it makes
the uh fund look a little different
uh so in line with it for guidance those
have been transferred into the uh ndr
earmarked reserve
um to be released to the fund uh to to
be released to fund the reliefs that we
need to apply in 2021-22
uh financial year
uh there are also two
large and corresponding covered related
variances the nine million overspend on
supplies and services and the equivalent
underspend on income uh is the
difference between the actual covered 19
grants received and paid versus the
amounts we expected when the budget was
set last september
and we didn't know at that point that we
were going to get more grants
and so this year two budgets have been
identified for rollover for which we
want uh cabinets approval please
uh 7k for gymnastics mats and
and that's only due to delays in the
supply chain
uh and 80k for
joint ict services for utilization in 20
year 21-22
those projects are ongoing so
uh
i'm i'm not going to go through
everything else in the report i just
want to point out a few things uh the
hra
is
is in
good shape and there are very few
variances of note and the out turn
position closely reflects the revised
budget
from september and a contribution to the
development reserve of 1.89 million um
has been made to invest in future
projects and and
that's been made at the year end and hra
balance is currently being maintained at
our
uh regular target at three million
um
capital programme uh yeah so the
appendix three details the capital
expenditure
uh ins then that's on a scheme by scheme
basis which is summarized at 2.24 in the
report
um as part of the report we'll be
seeking approval to carry forward 6.96
million in the capital programme
uh 2021-22
funding will also be rolled forward so
that
net impact is is nil
so um
and on treasury management
there's a report
in appendix 4
about the treasury management activity
for the council for this year
and the key points are summarized at 2.1
2.31 in the report
so um do members have any questions
on this report
thank you very much
uh and well done to yourself and and
jane and all the team for all the hard
work on this i know it's always a busy
time of year for you so thank you for
that any questions from anyone else
no
okay if not uh i'll move it on your
behalf counselor parking thank you as
i'm i'm present in the room
and council radical second all those in
favor
okay that's carried thank you very much
uh and then we come to the housing
strategy so i'm gonna hand over to
councillor powell to introduce this one
are you actually talking
sorry yes i am right okay
you're audible now yes if you could
thanks
that's probably because i've now put my
microphone on
thank you
um now then i've got to repeat what i
said before and i can't remember um no
seriously um this is the latest
iteration of a housing policy it's been
significantly reviewed and revised um
over the last 12 months to reflect
um the council's policies and um and
aspirations um it takes into account our
um
ability to
influence um our green agenda
uh for uh for reducing carbon emissions
um
it's
quite a complicated document it's quite
a challenging document
uh but i do think that it does give us
um a way forward
and
brings some clarity to what we really
want to do
with housing not just um rip through
written order but through our own
developments and also for the greater
good of the community as a whole
um
it now has a forward which i think is
excellent
um so i would recommend it to you ladies
and gentlemen
okay thank you very much about any other
comments or questions from anyone
no okay do you have a seconder
thank you
kenyan
and all those in favor
thank you okay so that's carried and
thank you very much for all the to all
the team again for all the work on that
and jill and and carl and everyone else
who i know will have put a lot of work
into that thank you very much
uh the next item is
uh
wrignald homes and social behavior
policies so it's back to you council
belt right and i've got the microphone
on this time
um
yeah we have to we have to publish a
policy we have to update policies from
time to time
um ricknold is our housing partner as
you all know
um the um the um
the policy itself
um has to comply with current
uh legislation
um this particular one um
creates awareness we are very conscious
of the fact that
all our tenants need to know what they
can do it also gives very precise
definitions of what asps are
um so from that point of view um i hope
it's something that all our tenants will
read and then they are
capable of making um
making complaints where they need to
but it also gives a roadmap for how
ricknall deal with complaints and how
they uh they they treat the tenants on
an ongoing basis
and it also widens the definition of of
um and social behavior so from that
point of view it's um it's a new
document
uh but it in fact reviews and revises
the old one
that basis chair i would recommend it to
you
okay thanks council pal i'm uh i'll
happily uh second the uh the report and
uh obviously we've had some discussions
with richmold holmes uh previous
meetings around this and it does seem to
be a
sensible step forward so i'm more than
happy to second any other comments or
questions for anyone
counselor cupid
[Music]
uh yeah just to say i really welcome uh
this report and this update for
residents i know it's the key issue
across the district uh and for many
residents in my ward and many others so
i just wondered if we can arrange some
relevant comms as well uh to update
residents on the process because i know
that's
speaking to residents that's obviously
often one of the things that they're not
sure when they're in this you know awful
situation what to do so just wanted to
flag that um and councillor powell's the
best person to do it really
thank you councillor cupid um i will
certainly take that on board oh i think
we've done it already
and thank you
excellent no that's great um i think
yeah probably all of us as local members
will have had some dealings with with
with uh um
tenants and residents around uh around
any social behavior issues so i think
that'll be very very very useful um okay
uh so we've had we've had the policy
introduced we've had it moved and
seconded so all those in favor
okay that's carried thank you very much
uh and then the next item is urgent
items of which there are none
and then finally i will
move to exclude the public so i move
that the public be excluded from the
meeting during the discussion of the
following items of business
to avoid the disclosure to them of
exempt information as defined in part
one of schedule 12a to the local
government act 1972 as amended by the
local government
access to information very variation
order 2006. do i have a second for that
council renick all those in favor
okay thank you that's carried
you